[Music]
when you play a new game for the first
time
you typically spend the first few hours
learning the basics
fundamentals like movement and
controlling your character
are essential after all you've got to
learn to walk
before you can run
i'm the best like already what am i
dying from
i got electrocuted or something but some
players prefer to spend
slightly more time mastering specific
mechanics before hopping into
matchmaking
they understand their games on a
molecular level
and are able to push the boundaries of
what is and
isn't possible
[Applause]
and pushing those limits in the rapidly
expanding world of valorant
is conor fleitz dykes the big brain
british raised player who after spending
thousands of hours trick shotting in
call of duty
and surfing in cs go has established
himself
as one of valorem's leading content
creators
yeah i'm going to go get him now we'll
go on oh
we'll give you a second
a frag artist whose creativity has not
only inspired
others to study his handiwork but has
launched a career that a year ago
he could only have dreamed of so how did
flights go from 360
no scoping scrubs and call of duty to
valrant's beloved
blast packing one trick and how is his
outrageous
style actually helping to raise the
game's skill ceiling
i'm gonna try flying knifing okay show
us shows
okay so well before he made his name
ambushing unsuspecting casuals and
valorant
where did fleitz's story begin well
flights grew up in warrington
england a large town located between
liverpool and manchester
known mainly for its museums and music
festivals but like most kids growing up
flight spent a lot of his time playing
video games which he was introduced to
by his father the rapture and clan game
and then
little games like that so i was always
into gaming from a young age with my dad
which seems like the story most people
have when they first get into it their
dad usually gets them a console or
something they play
after flights parents separated he ended
up moving in with his grandmother who
bought him his very first ps2
from there he ended up getting a ps3
where he poured
hours into call of duty which was the
franchise that really
ignited his interest in content creation
inspired by organizations like
phase and soar flights would rush home
from school
every single day and spend hours trying
to capture insane trick shots
this is when i fully like started gaming
a lot way too much
i used to uh trick shot on cod which a
lot of kids used to do and stuff i
like i used to do it like every day but
once the hype around call of duty began
to dwindle away he
turned his sights to cs go
kind of i had another friend from school
who used to play cs go
but he didn't use to play comp cs go he
used to just surf
he showed me videos on it and i had no
idea what cs go was i had no idea about
1.6
any of them games i had no clue fleitz's
interest
was peaked and so he began watching
videos of players surfing and bunny
hopping in custom servers
and the relaxing nature of it inspired
him to give it a shot
so i bought cs go and i didn't touch any
com any casual anything i just surfed on
the on the game for about
i'd say the first 1000 hours of playing
cs go i didn't touch a single bit of
comp or anything because
i didn't i didn't know about it or care
about it so i used to just surf and do
the bunny hop stuff
now for anyone out there who doesn't
actually know what surfing or bunny
hopping and counter-strike
is allow me to enlighten you surfing has
been a part of counter-strike since 2004
allegedly invented by a player named
marioned
marion realized that by holding down the
a or d
key on your keyboard you could control
your trajectory when sliding across
rooftops or
objects to gain more speed and this
combined with bunny hopping allowed
players to master the movement
of their character oh here we go already
surfing that usually happens later on
but you know obviously this is the
m4 duel that we're getting to he's
something he just doesn't care
whatsoever
and he has no idea bunny hoppers
essentially combine
jumping and strafing so that they're
able to gain momentum
in the air and propel themselves through
the map quicker
and with much more control and it's a
mechanic that serious cs go players
actively drill to sharpen their movement
around maps
just push himself inside of the higher
catwalk means one kill onto jinx though
and makes it a 1v1 lucky
on the back of the bombsite get right
dives on through
get right with a b-hop spray down
eventually after spending countless
hours mastering his in-game movement
flights finally got the sudden urge to
actually play cs go i don't know what
made me do it i just tried comp
on cs go and then really got into that
and got good at that pretty quick
and then mida i had another friend who
also played that i found out played cs
go and he told me about
face it in esea and i had no clue what
they was at the time was oh yeah he's
like no way you play cs and stuff i do
too i play
face it in the esa and stuff i was like
what is that i don't know what that is
from that point on flights was hooked
instead of surfing he began to
grind on face it in the hope that one
day
he might be able to compete
professionally and in no time he found
himself hitting rank
10 on the platform unfortunately for
flights breaking into cs go's
already well-established pro and content
creation scene
proved to be an uphill battle especially
considering the challenges he was facing
outside of the server after dropping out
of college
flight spent the majority of his time
working in an amazon warehouse
while taking care of his grandmother but
the monotony of his job was only making
him
miserable i had to walk all the way to
my town center which took about
it was like a 20 minute walk wait for a
coach that was always late half an hour
drive there
getting to work about a 10 hour shift on
my own 10 hour 10 hours goes by i'm like
okay done
wait for the coach again always late
walk home again so it was it ended up
being like
11 12 hour days on your own not really
speaking to anyone every single day
and i was like this is this is mentally
draining i can't do this but when
flights found out that his grandma
needed hip surgery in 2019
he decided to quit his job and
prioritize looking after her and so i
started caring for her and looking after
her so
i try to put as much time into all this
as i can but then there's a lot of times
where
i have to you know i'll care for my nan
if i do that in my spare time or
i'll try to just you know relax have
time for myself going
on other games off stream or something
although flights had a lot on his plate
he still dreamed of turning his passion
for gaming
into a profession and later that year
his ambition was
re-energized when riot games made an
exciting announcement
here it is project a is our
character-based tactical shooter
it's competitive it has precise gun play
it's set on a beautiful near future
earth
and it has a lethal cast of characters
each with their own unique abilities
this is our take on a competitive
shooter project a
or valorant as it would later be known
changed
everything for flights it offered him
the chance to get in on the ground
floor of a new and exciting game that
promised to have a fully formed
competitive scene
i wanted to try and be the best and
gopro like i had that in my mind
sort of but then i also had the thought
of
this could be a really big way to pop
off on youtube
or twitch with it early because if you
jump on it right away and you're doing
something no one else is doing
then this is a big chance to do it after
getting access to the beta in april of
2020
flights initially tried hitting
valorent's highest rank
by playing phoenix but it was when he
adopted
rays that he truly began to find his
groove
as an entry fragger i did a little boost
on haven it through mid
onto the mid boxes on b and i got a kill
with it
and i was like wait that was sick you
know like a little satchel boots like
that that was crazy
that was probably the first double
satchel thing on the game i ain't seen
any since then or anything i was like
that's crazy
i'm gonna try to do that again i'm gonna
try and make a video on on just that
so i was going into games and i was just
trying random spot
i was finding in custom games little
spots where i could place the satchel
and
soon as the barrier lifts i just jump
and try and get there
it's like insanely fast and once flights
realized the true potential behind
reyes's movement
he began dedicating all of his time to
mastering the agent's abilities
specifically her blastbacks he started
off with some relatively
basic plays before he really started
showcasing
the nearly endless possibilities with
the characters
it was becoming pretty obvious that
fleitz's vast experience in
counter-strike's movement communities
allowed him to unlock an entirely
different
element to raise his kit as his clips
made the rounds on reddit and his videos
hit millions of views
flights was already getting recognized
by the community as
the best raised player around you are
the best race player dude
i don't know about the best maybe with
the movement stuff
maybe and while his early montages were
a bit of a throwback to his cod trick
shotting days
flights has made sure that his
personality finds a way into his content
i need a wheeze so bad my about to
explode
i can feel it growing in circumference
it's actually becoming a
football in my pants in time flight's
growing celebrity led to him crossing
paths with
average jonas and flex ninja and through
their collaborations
they've famously become known as
valorant's
one trick trio
[Music]
yeah yes sir he's good at this game and
it wasn't just fleitz's peers that were
recognizing his
rising profile in january of 2021
he was approached with the opportunity
to take his content to the next level
one of the general managers of t1
reached out to me
oh god this then they'd signed tyler1
they had faker they had brax they had
all these people that because obviously
in cs go i looked up to them
to brac skadoodle everyone fake is
obviously one of the biggest
legends in all of gaming with league
tyler1 one of the biggest streamers this
was this huge
established big og but as grateful as
flights is for the explosion of his
streaming career amidst a global
pandemic
he is hopeful that once life goes back
to normal
he can finally return to one of his true
passions i got into muay thai in high
school
and i really enjoyed that and then
obviously started watching the ufc and
conor mcgregor started blowing up with
everything and then i was like
oh no mma is what i want to do now so i
started doing mma and i started
training at first i went to a gym in
manchester called spg manchester
which is the same like brandon as spg
island which conor mcgregor trained at
but that one at a time because i was
making like
no money it was way too expensive what
there was a
for how how many sessions you're doing
stuff like i i can't afford this but
obviously now
with this i i can afford it but there's
one issue we've got kovid everywhere so
nowhere is open now
regardless of whether he's popping jabs
in the gym
or skulls in the server there's no
question that
fleitz's sudden rise to success is a
symptom
of the work that he's been willing to
put in in the span of just
one year he has managed to transform his
lifelong passion for
gaming into a career that he truly
loves and as meteoric as his rise has
been
flights will never forget the humble
beginnings
from which it all started i all feel
surreal but the fact that it went from
just
a trick shot in with irl friends
thinking you know a little kid coming
home from school playing
to what it is now yeah i don't know it's
insane
i get the all by formula and then i'm
gonna go oh [ __ ] you're gone okay
oh you're dead is he on site
nothing heaven
gets grounded comfortable
6k
6k i'm getting a lot of [ __ ]
flack in the comments over valor and
[ __ ] and i don't really need to
i don't want to stoke the fires or just
like you can just tell in this guy's
voice that he hates mallory
what the [ __ ] do i say to that well
flights grew up in
warrington warrington warrington it's
not
worcestershire